setup tour it's finally time for my new
setup tour the long awaited
but first
i gotta check in what other people got
going on other youtubers last time i
reacted to pokemans and i can see now
there isn't
there's been an update i was being harsh
because our cable management was the
worst thing i've ever seen oh god the
cable management oh don't don't stop i
know stop judging me but i'm happy to
see that someone else
helped her take care of that's where
they all are
oh
nice that's so much better is everything
wireless in here wireless right
wait this is insane
she gets it
i have this amazing super expensive
setup but no cables this is amazing
where did they put the lights though oh
they put it on top that's so much better
that looks great you have the same
microphone
everybody still had the go xlr i refused
to have it so she has all this stuff on
the wall i don't really
get it it looks kind of i don't think
they do that much anyway if you have a
good microphone like i sound fine right
i don't think you need to put the stuff
on the wall i don't know they're just
such a pain to remove i put them on once
and i'm like this is not worth it over
here
some mistakes were made yep so she tried
to remove them too yeah they're just
such a pain to remove that's not worth
it
that's easy fix though anyway that's
great to see wholesome ending i also
reacted to mini miter minimiter i know i
know him obviously i just don't know how
to say your name mm7 simon bro i'm sorry
okay pewdiepie has mentioned me in one
of his latest videos
it's not good he uploaded my six billion
dollar setup tour what is this mm-hmm
what is it something different
how could i forget
i kind of roasted his setup a little bit
because it's like you don't need that
many monitors it has like six
one two three four oh yeah i think that
was the fifth one i don't know but
apparently he made an update like he had
made one right before my video went up
but as i said the one on the left is for
games and i don't use it anymore i only
have three monitors now i mean i don't
know okay tv and another display done
oh
i mean now it looks good like that's
just the results
that's so much cleaner yeah much much
better obviously not acceptable to my
standards of cables but still pretty
damn good because then you have two
computers too like that
commence of that i don't hate this all
right yeah i'm sorry dude it looks great
it looks amazing for this place to play
among us with you
four displays to play among us with you
and you don't even know
i know it's my favorite video of all
time another wholesome end the same guy
that held the
pokey setup techsource did a reaction to
my video and he doesn't look pleased so
let's check it out also why is it so
dark in this room
i like it dark
i'm a gamer now i have the brightest
room of all time i got these displayed
they're supposed to be like
non-reflective displays so i can see
fine
boys and girls in here
here is my ultimate gaming setup we got
triple
okay all right it looks better in the
dark come on i'll build you a custom pc
if you want no i want to build my own pc
but i appreciate y'all i even put this
now you want a fisherman friend bro
he's got a freaking pencil drawer yo
let's freaking go that's what i'm
talking about
yeah it's super useful yeah you don't
want to i don't have stuff on my table
this guy gets it holy bass see this is
what i mean he's got the cable sleeve
just kind of bridging across into a uh
looks like a cable box on the opposite
side
um i'm assuming he did that because his
desk is a sit-and-stand desk so he's
using the cable slack to lift and um
lower the desk he gets it if it wasn't i
would most likely route those cables
alongside the leg piece using like
velcro straps or whatever um and then
alongside the wall so for a much cleaner
look but yeah that's actually what i did
on this setup so that's cool
he gets it this guy gets it i'm also
gonna react to you guys set up just like
last time oh joel posted i want to see
this
[Laughter]
10 out of 10 my dude
ignoring the cables and the fact that
it's completely broke it does look kind
of sick like before it broke it probably
looked cool
well 10 out of 10 because you're
watching the greatest youtube channel of
all time that looks nice
very simple and clean yes also 10 out of
10 because you're watching the grid
too many cables man come on man did you
pick the smallest display you could find
or
i actually looked online like gaming
displays are not that expensive anymore
this one was 200 bucks and it's huge
like it's kind of crazy and 165 hertz
that was cool very personalized i like
that hey
it always looks clean having that i said
this before all the monitors
hung up and i think especially the way
you did it looks really clean it looks a
little bit like a kitchen with the
drawers but other than that yeah really
really really nice you also have the
thing for your pet underneath the desk i
like that or maybe you just want your
feet to feel [ __ ] i don't know oh this
is a cool one very unique your eyes
while gaming there and there
where do i look
it looks good though on photo i'm sure
you're just using one at a time don't
mind the cabling which cable i can't see
nothing
floor game
hell yeah someone still got it gundam
gang oh there they are sick poor gang oh
gables a no excuse to not organize your
cables looking good what are these
setups dude
i'm sorry what
oh
very clean just a keyboard and a mouse
and the cover and nothing else looking
great it's looking i can't really see
what's going on but it's looking cozy
and i think that's all that matters
something holy [ __ ] that is so theme
iced got spy family happening and a lot
of pink okay it's kind of sick i like it
that's also very sick i like that one a
lot actually hey you got the pewdiepie
headphones and the background yeah
yeah that's great sure
oh you got the new chair i didn't
realize people already had that that's
crazy hell yeah you've been drinking the
pewdiepie g fuel as well
those are so good i see people post them
all the time because they're stocked in
america
in walmart i think i wish i could get
them here they're so good yeah another
one with the greatest flavor of
pewdiepie drain very clean i like when
the the setup shows a bit of personality
like this like it's not what i would go
with obviously but it's cool
whoa we got some crafty gunpla [ __ ] here
that's sick i was wondering like because
i used to have one of those painting
studio boxes that he has and you need to
exhaust the air from it i was wondering
how you do that without making it look
terrible and i think you did a great job
actually that's really cool because like
here
i don't know how i would possibly custom
paint gumplus this is not enough space
for it oh and oh yeah so last video i
reacted to someone having like a really
bad chair and i was like clutch can we
hook her up and they actually did we
should show that side that's funny all
right good stuff guys but i think uh i'm
seeing improvement as well very nice i
think that's enough updates let me show
you guys around this setup finally
japan edition welcome
come in
[Music]
it's finally done it is done
yeah take it in
we're gonna buff all our stats in here
strength dexterity intelligence i know
it's a bit odd to have the gym in here
but i like it
i've always wanted to have a proper
setup even though this is kind of tiny
i'm very happy with it i finally
got my home gym this is a huge
improvement for me i i really like it to
figure out this room i was like should i
put a sofa here we were talking about
emiya marzia
then we could have like a guest room for
people and stuff like that but no
i'm swedish there will be no hospitality
for guests i'm gonna i want to use it
come back okay you can come
i wanna have something i will actually
use instead of
i don't know if someone comes over what
will it be like one percent of the time
i don't know less
it just seems a bit like wasteful so i
went with what i want and what i want is
a home gym setup i know it looks a bit
odd but i love it it's great
so this is a half power rack it saves me
a little bit of space because a yeah
full one would go out here
even just being able to do
pull ups
just being able to do that it's such a
nice change of pace i've always just
used these dumbbells
using a barbell finally is so fun uh
doing squats and
all that jazz dead lifts i maxed out the
bench press on my dumbbell so i can
finally add more to my bench press
yeah very happy with it it's kind of a
flimsy amazon shaky one but it does
that's a job it looks alright it is a
very cramped space though like i don't
have much space
here i have to be careful i don't break
the wall or something i don't know
hello
that's very close
in my last workout video i was
complaining how i hate leg day but now
that i have a barbell leg day is
actually really fun like doing proper
squats
i have a cover for it though
and dead lace it's so much more fun with
the barbell with the dumbbells it works
obviously but it's so much more fun
there's so much
more i can do now and
yeah we're gonna get them games
really
so yeah that's my gym shout out we have
kind of like a line here i don't know if
you could tell to kind of work with i
spent so much time trying to figure out
this room because it's such an odd shape
like you have this area
look at iggy
i have these for
for storage
the thing is it also makes it impossible
to use all this space like for the
i would like to put more floor mats but
i
can't open the doors if i do so
i don't really know what the architect
was going with putting the doors here i
would much rather have them here
because the the room is so long
it was really hard to plan it out i used
like a 3d program and i spent so much
time trying to move stuff around does
this make sense especially when you
order stuff online you never know the
full size unless you've really like seen
it in front of you so i was really
worried it was gonna feel too cramped in
here but i think it totally works that
was the thing with the desk as well like
i kept looking at desks might say we'll
know how long i was going crazy trying
to just find the right desk a lot of
them were just like kind of bad and
flimsy
uh so i find this company that
just did the wood panels so it's two
desks put together
basically it's not supposed to be an
l-shaped desk but i made it into it
which worked out great i'm super happy i
have an l-shaped desk finally because
say hi to maya hello maya
she really likes it there edgar doesn't
like this bed he doesn't sleep in it he
sleeps there
we'll have to get your your own bed eggy
are you gonna go into bed
you wanna stay with me don't you
sorry iggy
is my gamer setup
super nice
i wanted a really
wide desk here and then i have a slimmer
one here so i can build my gun then
before i would sit on the floor building
gundam it was awful so to have a
dedicated space for a hobby is
so nice i love it super nice
very pleased with it
i'm super proud of this setup i think it
worked that gray
edgar what do you think what would you
rate it
great
he likes it
so i used to have the
ultra wide monitor which i really like
don't get me wrong but i wanted to try
out i've seen so many people used to
like a portrait mode display so i wanted
to try it out and it's actually really
nice it's basically like a glorified uh
glorified spotify playlist
display
i do miss the ultra wine but i think
this is a really good solution it's
usually kind of awkward when you have
many displays like where do you put the
camera so
you guys sit there
you see me here you get some background
it's nice
very pleased with it
clutch gaming is going to cry because
i'm not using their keyboard i wanted a
japanese layout keyboard okay sorry
this mouse is really bad but i wanted to
try a wireless one
no cables i hate cables cables are the
enemy
the devil but it looks nice
no cables you guys want to talk cables
with me
check this out
look at this
glorious cable management
yes
so it's all coming in here and then
here we have the power and i can still
access and add more stuff if i wanted to
then we have all the extra cables hidden
in this one then the cables go down here
you can barely see it and then i have
another power
strip here i don't think i need it i
could probably move it in here but it
doesn't really matter and then all the
power comes from behind the speaker over
there
i think i did a really good job
i feel like the cable thing is a meme
and i was like i don't really care that
much but actually i'm a replaced it
looks good it looks super clean i'm very
pleased with it
i feel like the behind of a gamer setup
is always like the ugliest bit but it
doesn't even look that bad we got the
clutch chair
new edition
it fits my setup so well cause uh
yeah it's more of a black and white kind
of setup i didn't want to have too many
like rgb and i don't know gamer lights
and epic
so i think this one this does has and it
does have rgb but
it's such a good chair
look
you think it's not gonna go
it goes
you mean you think it's gonna handle the
handle
i got one of these to put my g-fuel in
which made sense but i never use it i
don't think it makes sense
and of course gotta have your drawer
with all your stuff
keep the egg this is my video something
clingy stop it no
i'm showing my pencil drawer right here
yeah i gotta keep all your stuff there
nice
i also got another one here
uh
that i can put on my gundam crap in
this is echo space and then it makes it
cozy for my ad doesn't it
do you love the setup maya what would
you rate the setup 10 out of 10
11 out of 10. it looks better at nine
obviously like most gaming setups but
simple it's clean i got a new computer
here i've always wanted to build a
computer and i was so sure i was gonna
build my own when i came to japan but
once we came here we just had so much to
do and set up that i just felt like i'm
not gonna have time to do it right now
i'll have to do it in the future i just
got a custom pre-built one
it's
it's good enough that's just what i went
with it looks alright and it runs really
well it's way better than my
my other computer so
yeah it's all right
so it's 32 gigabyte ram
intel i9
250 gigahertz
it's got a motherboard
i don't know much about computers
it's good it's a good computer super
strong gaming computer stronger than the
strongest japanese man
chair still does this
oh
this by the way huh isn't that nice
all the girls have a pegboard i have a
string board
and check this out this is swedish
design
and it's made by tree fiber plastic
smelly it smells like wood
a little bit
she gave a nod of a little bit
so if you ever want to smell my boxes
free to do so
everyone asked me about my uh
my background and my nds that i have in
my last video these are called i think
it's called rain
meter and the skin is omni my ui
definitely download that it's really
good uh and then i just have some random
animated wallpaper i don't remember
sorry my speakers this is the first
thing i bought when i two years ago or
three years ago when i came to japan i'm
like i want to have good speakers
there's always been a dream of mine i
have good speakers
uh
they're a bit over the top
but they are amazing let me play
something
whoa
that was loud
[Music]
greatest song it's also nice when i'm
working out i can actually have good
speakers as well and whenever it
connects to my computer so
people probably say these are over
expensive why would you buy them but i
love them it's the kind of product
you'll have for the rest of your life
honestly
well for a long time at least super cool
design danish good job denmark you did
something great happy birthday
glory of sweden
ikea gundam
beautiful
they made it over all the way safely out
i was so worried it wasn't gonna we'll
be building more epic custom builds this
one took me so damn long it doesn't look
like it i'm super proud of it i didn't
used to be like a fiddly guy i didn't
like to do put too much time into stuff
but it kind of taught me that it's worth
it got most of my books here i didn't
bother keeping a lot of the ones that i
don't like and
i got a newer version of the ones i did
in case they look fresh
got the iliad got the odyssey
beautiful
you're from years
the the greatest one of them
what do you think what would you rate
the setup
all right i guess i can show something
bad about this setup this the thing is
like i wanted both my speakers right
but
you can't have symmetry in this room
unfortunately which
you know i was talking about this liner
earlier that i had to keep in mind i
kind of had to break it here for the
speaker
so i can't open this door
i mean i can open and get in fine this
is i can't open this one which hey what
are you gonna do i don't know
i don't understand why they put the
doors there i really don't the room is
too long already
originally what i was thinking was i was
gonna put like a desk here and then
super minimalist
it was going to look like a magazine and
oh it looks so cool but i'm like i want
to actually use this space you know same
with the workout thing i know it looks
odd but this is the stuff i like and i
want to use it and i definitely made the
right choice i'm super pleased with this
i already love it uh there will be many
epic gaming moments made here we're
gonna buff all our stats hell yeah what
do you guys think let me know i think
this one is upgrade for my last one for
sure yeah
i'm very pleased with it all right well
that's it for this tour now get out of
here go smash like subscribe for more
see ya
bye bye
a quick word of a sponsor nordvpn the
greatest vpn of all time not just
because it has nord in the name and i'm
a nord as well but because it is the
greatest vpn it's fast it's reliable and
i think it's a little sexier than all
the other ones on the market but that's
just my opinion why should you use a vpn
well why should you care about
protecting yourself huh
protecting yourself from spyware
now with a new feature called threat
protection taking your cyber security to
the next level and you don't even have
to be connected to a vpn to use it it's
just a protection constantly keeping you
guarded shielded like the strongest
nordic viking shield it is actually
legit and it works really well another
great reason to use a vpn as you know
i'm in japan now i can still watch my
shows thank you nordvpn
with one simple click
i am back in england and now we can
watch love island
thank you
it's risk free so if you want to check
it out for 30 days use the link in the
description and get money back guarantee
baby that's nordvpn.com pewdiepie check
it out it's worth trying out there's a
huge deal on a two-year plan where you
get discount and one month for free link
is in the description that's the way you
get the offer and thank you norviv for
sponsoring this video